[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZISL SLEPOVITCH: Hello.
My name is Zisl
Slepovitch and I'm
musician in residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust
Testimonies.
This video series is designed
as a companion to our album
Where is our Homeland?,
which is the first volume
in the Archive's ongoing
effort to present
songs and poems performed
by survivors in testimonies
given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more
about the project
on the Archive's website
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where is our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies:
Volume 1 was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble
featuring renowned singer Sasha
Lurje, Craig Judelman
on the violin,
Joshua Camp on the accordion,
keyboards, and guitar,
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass,
and myself on woodwinds.
The songs in this
collection differ vastly
in terms of style, social
and historical background,
language, and many
other aspects.
But collectively, they create
a multidimensional picture
of Jewish life before
and during World War II.
One of the most musically and
ethnographically compelling
testimonies in the
Fortunoff Video Archive
is the one given by Jack M.,
a native of the Polish town
of Dzialoszyce.
Jack had an impressive
memory and was
a great storyteller and singer.
It is noteworthy
that Jack was also
recorded for The Folk
Song Project carried out
in the 1980s.
Jack remembered really a wealth
of the pre-war traditional
Jewish repertoire, including
badkhones wedding jesters,
recitatives, folk songs of
all kinds, songs in Polish,
some of which he learned
while serving in the army.
One of the most
mesmerizing Yiddish songs
Jack sang on his
testimony was Trayb di
khvalyes "Drive Your
Waves Deep River."
It is a song performed
on behalf of a woman who
is longing for her beloved
on the bank of a deep river.
And she asks the river to tell
him about her bitter fate.
This is a pagan Slavic
trait, which is also
referred to as folk Judaism.
Superstitions and dialogue
with the forces of nature
and other borrowings from
the para-religious beliefs
of the Slavic, Baltic, Finnish,
Moldavian, and Romanian
neighbors took their firm
place in the Jewish folklore,
which shouldn't come
as a surprise given
the 650-year long
history of coexistence.
And this song is
not an exception.
The melody is typical for the
Eastern Slavic rural lyrical
song of the 19th century,
with its characteristic
intrasyllabic vocalization
and wide vocal range.
JACK M.: She is singing like
she was standing by the ocean
to the waves
instead of a letter.
She gave the song like this.
(SINGING) Drive your
waves, deep river
Drive them over mountains
and valleys
From afar, I send my beloved
A thousand greetings
She repeats this twice.
(SINGING) Tell him, deep
river, Of my bitter fate.
Of my bitter fate.
For my life is like
a dismal valley,
Without a ray of sunlight
Those two I remember.
But there was a third one,
but I can't remember it.
[ENSEMBLE PLAYING]
SASHA LURJE: (SINGING)
Drive your waves, deep river
Drive them over mountains
and valleys
From afar, I send my beloved
A thousand greetings.
Tell him, deep river,
Of my bitter fate.
For my life is like
a dismal valley,
Without a ray of sunlight.
For my life is like
a dismal valley,
Without a ray of sunlight.
[ENSEMBLE PLAYING]
Di ertsayl im, tifer taykh,
Fun mayn bitern shikzal,
Az mayn leybn iz vi ayn triber tul.
On a zin un on shtral.
ELEONORE BIEZUNSKI:
Jack M. recalls
that he learned some of the
songs he knows from hoyfzinger
and gassenzinger, courtyard
and street singers
who would come from
Warsaw to his town
and sing the latest hits.
But he learned this
particular song
from the balebosta
the female boss--
in a shop where he was
apprenticing as a tailor.
She would sing songs as she was
working, including lullabies.
In his testimony, Jack
compares this song
to a letter addressed to
a lover who has gone away.
He remembered two
verses of what must
have been a longer ballad,
comparable to the well-known
papier iz dokh veys,
or dortin dortin,
similar to other
Yiddish love songs
in the style of
this European genre,
reminiscent of the Russian
and German folk repertoires.
The renowned
folklorist Ruth Rubin
wrote in her 1973 book Voices
of a People that, I quote,
"an examination of 19th
century Yiddish love songs
will reveal many parallels
with old German love
songs of several centuries ago.
While other authors contain
only fragmentary evidence
of this early ancestry, the bulk
of Yiddish folk songs today,
however, relate mainly to
19th century life of the Jews
in the Czarist
Pale of Settlement.
Within this framework,
these love songs
were the forerunners
which inspired
the first generations
of Yiddish lyric
poets in modern Yiddish
literature," end of quote.
As the co-coordinator of the
Ruth Rubin legacy website,
I have heard many such songs,
that you can also now access
easily since close to 2,000
songs have been digitized
and are now online as
part of this project.
It is notable that
this type of songs
was often transmitted
through women who--
although they were not allowed
to perform publicly, mostly
because of religious reasons--
would sing abundantly
in their homes
and, like in the case of
Jack's balebosta at work.
The emotions of the songs
are conveyed through images
of nature in Trayb di khvalyes.
The mountains and valleys
represent the greetings
that the singer wishes to
send to their lost love.
At the same time, they
symbolize the very distance
separating the singer
from their loved ones,
while the waves can
be seen as reflecting
the agitated emotional state
caused by their heartbreak
and longing.
As the joke goes, if you find
yourself in a Yiddish love
song, stay away from the river.
The same could be said
of other European folk
songs, where desperate
lovers sometimes
ends up drowning themselves.
Although this song doesn't
present such a tragic ending,
the topography of the
feelings in the last two lines
convey bitterness through
the idea of depth,
whether it is the
valley, the river,
or the image of darkness.
In their arrangement
of this song,
the Zisl Slepovitch
Ensemble and Sasha Lurje
have created a texture with
drone-like accompaniment
and unison in the melody, which
emphasizes both the lyricism
of the text and the underlying
darkness expressed within.
It's a beautiful work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]